المبادره الاخلاص وحب العطاء انا فاطمه
الاحمد عضو مجلس الاستشاري لمؤسسه الغرير
للتعليم وعظه القيادات الاعلاميه العربيه
الشابه وعضو مجلس راس الخيمه للشباب
اماراتيه شغوفه بالاعمال التطوعيه
[موسيقى]
رحله التغيير بدات مع والدي الشيخ زايد بن
سلطان ال نهيان طيب الله ثراه رمز الخير
والعطاء واليوم انا اكمل على نهجه في
ترسيخ ثقافه البذل والعطاء الانسانيه
الاماراتيه انطلاقه كانت من كليات التقنيه
العليا ببنت ساعات العمل التطوعي من هنالك
بدات مسيرته في الاعمال التطوعيه واليوم
انجزت اكثر من سته الاف ساعه عمل تطوعي
وبعد ذلك انضمنت الى الفريق الوطني
للاستجابه لحالات الازمات والكوارث بدات
الدوره الاساسيه في المتقدمه في الدورات
التخصصيه في الاسعاف الجوي والرعايه
الصحيه مما اهلني للانضمام الى خط الدفاع
الاول لمواجهه فايروس
كان عائلتي دور كبير في دعمي معنويا عنده
انضمامي لفريق التطوعي للاستجابه للحالات
الازمات والكوارث لمواجهه كورونا وكذلك في
استكمال دراستي في مجال العمل الانساني
المستمر
فلما بلغت اهلي اني انا بنظم لخطي الدفاع
الاول في البدايه كان في القليل من التخوف
بحكم ان الجائحه ما عندنا معلومات عنها
وكان شيء
صعب يمر في العالم ولكن
ساعدوني معنويا وشجعوني على اني انا اكون
في الخطوط في صفوف الخطوط الاولى
طبعا انا اليوم اكمل الدراسات العليا في
مجال العمل الانساني المستدام اخترت هذا
التخصص بالذات واللي هو او التخصص الاول
من نوعها في العالم في هذا تخصص لان اليوم
نحنا نحتاج الى حلول مستدامه في مجال
العمل الانساني
فاليوم نحنا ما نعطي الصياد لسمكه ولكن
نعلمه كيف يصيد ذلك نحتاجه في مجال
الاعمال الانسانيه اليوم احنا ما نقدم فقط
لهم همم
مؤقت ولكن نقدم لهم حلو المستدامه حلمي ان
يوم من الايام تكون لي مؤسسه الخاصه في
مجال الاعمال الانسانيه واني اقدر اوصل
للاجيال القادمه مفهوم الاعمال الانسانيه
[موسيقى]